eu tenho que contar uma história tem a
ver com superpoderes mas não é igual a
isso
seu problema é superfã deixa estão mais
associados a minha realidade e atua há
dias atrás eu estava em casa de um amigo
com o irmão mais novo dele ficamos de
conversar seja uma pergunta então beto
como é que foi em agosto foram lá muito
seus colegas já escolhemos por acaso na
hungria e agora chamado mais mas é algo
que por acaso na mangueira não estava lá
muito a deus
alegou ter um trabalho de escola para
terminar
por isso não puderam gastar a resposta
do verdão fez me pensar ele acordar um
par daquilo que foi meu trajeto da
escola secundária até hoje quando
terminei o ensino secundário em filha
12ª classe a e eu não tinha uma idéia
exata do que eu queria fazer
eu pertencia a um grupo de amigos
fizeram assaltos fizeram mais bonitos
eu era um quase que sem um outro vôo em
particular ponte da casa
ah então descobri que eu poderia me
safar no grupo
se eu fosse mais inteligente se eu fosse
a pessoa que tivesse mais no meu grupo
todos os meus amigos têm inclinação
natural para tecnologias inclusive mas
na hora de servir para que conseguir no
ensino superior
eu decidi fazer ciências sociais
a lógica era simples na universidade eu
aprendi as ciências sociais em casa
abriria tecnologias com os meus amigos
a gente sabia duas vezes conseguia certa
forma me destacar no grupo através desse
conhecimento
hangu na faculdade com a fazer é
escolher os futuros da economia
quando eu ia estudando economia
eu conhecia da anchieta para quem não
conhece adoecimento é considerado o pai
da economia moderna da dancinha de certa
forma me impressionaram porque eu queria
teorias como o mundo funciona lá da
economia
queria ser como a dança poder criar
teorias pudessem influenciar e talvez
melhorar a vida das pessoas
à medida que estudando o plano foi certa
forma ficando frustrado eu descobri cada
um assumindo posturas teorias décadas
atrás e que as mesmas teorias a 1 o
encore o mixto conseguiu adicionar
alguns parágrafos quando estava a fazer
seu pega de matemática na universidade
princeton e psicologia chama janete
comecei a ficar mais consciente sobre o
trabalho com teria para conseguir ser o
comandante mesmo teria que estar no
mínimo nos calcanhares do jô nesta eu
não era tão bom em matemática assim da
minha formação eu sempre tive interesse
por atividades extracurriculares
e por esse interesse acabei conhecendo
acabei conhecendo acabei andando com uma
dos meus amigos
os nerds não demorou muito e também
tornar um líder desta deste grupo há
alguém chega da minha porque eu mantenho
me fiel meu planeta se ao que ela tinha
que saber mais que os meus amigos do
conhecimento ciências sociais permitiram
tá no grupo e poder saber de tecnologias
que aprender com isso e saber de gestão
do projeto
mais do que a gestão de pessoas
mantenham realmente tenta a este grupo
hoje é um dos mais influentes no país
certa forma não mudar o futuro conserva
tecnologias que vão seguir este grupo
hoje é capaz de criar aplicações que vão
criar um pacto no qual fez por igual a
ti é com os meus conhecimentos de
ciências sociais mais tarde eu acabei
por ir trabalhar por uma das empresas
mais inovadoras e também trabalhando do
mercosul as mais fantásticas que já
conhecia o teor da minha vida
certa forma eu mantenha fiel aos meus
instintos
hoje acontece com freqüência para os
meus amigos vêm me perguntar eu como
fazer isto como é que tu consegues fazer
as coisas que tu faz
qual é o segredo quando eu souber poder
no extinto superpoder na 12ª classe
quando eu sabia que minha inclinação
natural era para tecnologias no extinto
disso para fazer ciências sociais
assim eu fiz certa forma mudou
aquilo que a minha realidade hoje esse
mesmo instinto me diz hideraldo ferido
formação que havia um atalho para
conseguir criar um pacto como
adolescente que não precisavam vender a
teorias certa forma um pacto que eu
procurava não estava só no ano seguinte
fora
foi quando cheguei a ganhar os meus
amigos aqui lá dos óculos e foi graças
ao meu instinto que eu conseguir ser o
que eu sou hoje
acredito aqui onde nós médicos
economistas professores gestores de
projetos perguntou vocês podem até ser
bom tino que vocês fazem
mas o que você extinto os diz que vocês
têm que fazer eu gostaria poder nos
ajudar com a resposta mas não gosta
vocês são os únicos que sabem o que se
passa nas vossas cabeças
vocês são os únicos que podem ouvir
vocês tinta foi que eu fiz eu não tenho
certeza que muita coisa nessa vida é ser
sincero eu acho que uma das coisas mais
confusas que eu conheço mas sempre
confio no meu instinto certa forma nunca
me deixou na mão
minha pergunta para você um agora o
vosso instinto me diz para fazer chegar
[Aplausos]